allez est notre invité politique ce
matin sur les jaguars bonjour bonjour
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour stéphane bern et
bonjour aux regards des fans qui dirige
le bureau parisien du journal ouest
france
on commence évidemment par la crise
sanitaire est d'abord une question déjà
vais voir comment vous avoisine bachelot
elisabeth bornes toutes deux positifs
aux collines écouter sans déflorer de
secret spécifique j'ai envoyé un petit
mot à elisabeth bornes jeu j'ai j'avais
pas le 06 de roselyne bachelot pour tout
vous dire mais je suis aussi fait passer
un petit mot elles sont courageuses
comme tous les français qui ont été
contaminés elles sont fatiguées par set
ce virus qui est très épuisant et les
français pour beaucoup le savent aussi
et elles sont courageuses comme beaucoup
les français ici elle se repose un peu
tout en suivant leurs dossiers avec leur
équipe mais ça va être assez fortement
touchée par ce virus est un virus qui ne
nous laissent pas tranquille globalement
j'ai pas eu encore à le confronter mais
j'ai eu beaucoup d'amis autour de moi
qui ont été touchés et beaucoup d'amis
parlementaires notamment qui des mois et
des mois d'ailleurs après la
primo-infection sont toujours épuisé
donc c'est bruno le maire qui avait été
touché bruno le maire est un sportif il
a une très bonne hygiène de vie je peux
vous dire on vit ensemble dans bercy à
plusieurs ministres et quand vous voyez
comment un gaillard aussi costaud que
bruno a pu être aussi touchés et si on
est certes remis mais c'est pas c'est
pas rien cette pandémie et je comprends
l'énervement je comprends l'agacement je
vais vous dire je comprends tout ce que
j'ai lu depuis quelques jours dans la
presse que j'ai entendu sur les plateaux
je comprends que c'est compliqué je
comprend parfois même la colère je
comprends la lassitude mais je crois
aussi qu'il faut qu'on tienne encore
cher 92 mille morts 35000 contamination
jour en ce moment c'est pas fini on a le
droit d'être en colère
le droit quand vous faites comprenait la
colère quand il prenait l'agacement est
ce qu'elles font part de responsabilité
du gouvernement dans cette colère est
dans cet agacement une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis fier d'appartenir au
gouvernement de jean castex et qu'il ya
toujours une raison d'être responsable
quand on est au gouvernement
et cette colère on est là pour
l'entendre et pour la chute mais aussi
hélas comprendre je vais pas vous dire
que c'est simple il ya une chose que je
vais dire simplement oui c'est compliqué
mais c'est aussi compliqué parce qu'on a
décidé de laisser beaucoup de choses
ouvert de laisser la vie continuer à
avancer et de ne pas nous remettre sous
cloche comme ça avait été le cas l'an
passé et parfois je suis assez frappé de
voir notamment de la part de certaines
oppositions des attaques qui sont pas à
la hauteur du débat et de l'enjeu je
vais quand j'entends il a loupé son pari
le président de la république je veux
dire ça me met en colère c'est par un
jeu c'est pas un pari c'est la vie des
gens dont on parle ici vous dire que ce
serait confortable ce serait mentir vous
dire qu'on fait tout pour essayer de
vivre quand même et que c'est complexe
oui je lâche une volontiers et qu'on
s'adapte en permanence je m'adapte je
laisse lui aussi volontiers
bon on vous dit que vous comprenez ça
tombe bien ce que nous on comprend pas
tout on a besoin d'explications dedans
avec les miens dehors citoyens c'est la
nouvelle expression utilisée par le
gouvernement pour nous expliquer ce qui
se passe ce que vous pourriez il faut il
le préciser un petit peu oui même si les
idées pourquoi est ce qu'on entend dire
des espèces de slogans comme ça quand on
dit les choses sans faire d'effort
d'explication avec des mots simples on
nous le reproche et je suis la première
à le faire quand on fait un travail
assez simple de rester avec les siens
chez soi est resté citoyens quand on est
dehors en gardant les gestes barrière en
faisant attention à pas être trop
nombreux en faisant attention à pas à
pas aller voir des personnes fragiles 11
ans je crois pas que ce soit si
compliqué après je ne voulais pas être
fait jeudi dès jeudi dernier ont fait et
je vois la critique depuis jeudi depuis
vendredi jerry buss
bien sûr mais il ya aussi un jeu
compliqué mais j'ai jamais dit je vous
le redis que ça va être simple il ya
l'autre truc est très simple qui est de
dire écoutez on laisse tout ouvert on
laisse tout faire mais ce sont deux
risques entre lesquels le gouvernement
est obligé de tracer un chemin
d'équilibré
on aurait pu par facilité d'autres pays
européens autour de nous le font
regardez nos voisins italiens
regardez ce qu'a dit hier encore la
chancelière merkel est ce que c'est
facile en allemagne entre l'état et les
lander et c'est parce que j'ai choisi
cette voie mais dire qu'on est bouillant
entre 210 et aussi de nous on s'est
vraiment fait retrouver sam troisième
voie entre le tout ou rien on essaye de
vivre quand même malgré des restrictions
et j'assume volontiers que c'est
compliqué et j'assume volontiers je
crois que bruno le maire l'a fait hier
aussi qui assureront des choses qu'il va
falloir adapter le petit jeu consistant
à tout dire les cordonniers mais pas les
vendeurs de chaussures les bien sûr mais
beaucoup ont beau jeu et je voudrais
bien les y voir je vais vous dire j'ai
pas dit que c'était facile et à bercy je
peux vous dire qu'avec les secteurs
économiques l 100 et 110 quel secteur va
rester ouvert quel secteur doit rester
fermée c'est un crève coeur de tous les
jours ses arbitrages
bon on les prend on les tient l'option
facile et vous êtes des gens ancrés dans
les territoires mais j'étais encore
toute la journée dans le gers
on me l'a dit l'option facile c'était
quand même deux tours refermer désir
allez hop on circule rien à voir c'est
pas l'option qu'on a prise et on a pris
une option plus complexe une option qui
fait rire certains malintentionnés
en attendant on fait en sorte que les
gens puissent continuer à travailler on
fait en sorte que nos enfants continuent
à aller à l'école le premier ministre a
raison de le rappeler combien dans nos
dans nos voisins européens ont gardé
cette ces écoles ouvertes
combien d'enfants en allemagne en italie
pendant des mois n'ont pas eu accès à
l'école il ya ce qu'on fait avec
difficulté à ce qu'on fait aussi envers
et contre tous avec une certaine forme
de courage et j'ai encore une fois
jamais dit que c'était simple
ça va s'éclaircir et les français sont
en emballant les élus locaux vous les
entendez vous aussi largement peut-être
entendu edouard philippe le maire du
havre qui dit lui qu'il évoquait une
mauvaise surprise que les mesures prises
dans sa ville du havre ne sont pas
justifiés en fonction d'eux
l'état de la crise sanitaire dans sa
ville qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
cette déclaration des leurs philippe je
pense que c'est peut-être pas il le sait
mieux que moi aujourd'hui le cas wavre
gens pensent que la réalité de ce
variant et qu'il va beaucoup plus vite
qu il tape beaucoup plus fort fort en
matière d'infections et contamination et
que en 24 48 72 heures la physionomie
une situation sanitaire peu bougé
freiner sans enfermer oui l'objectif
c'est de faire en sorte que ce variante
n'explose pas non certains départements
dans certains endroits où il semblerait
qu'il soit encore sous contrôle
l'objectif c'est justement de faire en
sorte qu'ils n'explosent pas les
italiens par exemple qui ont re confiné
très largement les trois quarts du pays
sont devant une situation où en quelques
jours en 48 72 heures les contaminations
ont explosé pour des raisons assez assez
complexe à comprendre avec des jeunes
qui arrivant aux urgences sans aucune
comorbidités avec des réalités sanitaire
qu'on n'avait pas vu sur la première
pandémie
donc on anticipe aussi on ne le ferai
pas je ne doute pas que ça nous
rapproche sur la liste des commerces ce
que dit le chemin est compliqué à
trouver est ce que cette liste elle est
amenée à évoluer il ya des commerces
fermés aujourd'hui qu'ils vont rouvrir
demain
mais oui c'est amené à évoluer je vais
vous dire que sincèrement au tour de
bruno le maire alain griset tous les
jours on y travaille on s'adapte à ce
que tous les jours notamment dans nos
déplacements il ya encore on nous parle
de certaines situations et comme je
découvre il ya des chu alors c'est plus
des sujets que des commerces parmi les
enjeux que nous n'avons pas résolu et
sur lesquels nous travaillons en
permanence y est le sujet des fonds de
commerce c'est à dire des fonds de
commerce qui aurait été rachetée l'an
passé qui n'ont pas de chiffre
d'affaires référent sur la période
précédant il ya le problème russie de la
polyactivité c'est pas facile notamment
dont dans certaines villes
dans certains villages de montagne dont
certains espaces ruraux vous avez des
commerces qui ont plusieurs activités
quelles parties de l'activité on prend
pour la baisse de chiffre d'affaires
voilà à quoi on s'attelle tous les jours
donc on y était je dirais avant ces
mesures annoncées jeudi j'étais encore
en q1 j'ai la semaine dernière et et je
le dis
on est encore en train de travailler sur
des mesures d'adaptation qui date du
précédent confinement donc si bien on
est en adaptation permanente ce qu'on
disait alain griset lui-même qui parle
d' aberration dimanche il a parlé d'
habermas chacun est libre chacun des
mots moi je suis mardi à bonjour chez
vous je parle pas d' aberration je parle
de choses qui sont compliqués je parle
de français qui peuvent aussi entendre
un langage de vérité qui est absolument
pas avant infantilisant qui est
d'arrêter de faire prendre des choses
pour ce qu'elles ne sont pas oui c'est
compliqué oui c'est galère oui on
s'adapte et comme dans toutes les
mesures politiques un peu courageuse y
aura su certainement des adaptations et
des choses qu'on aura ma nouvelle par
jean cassegrain voyez on dit jamais ce
qu'on a bien fait on dit jamais quand
plfr 4 l'an dernier projet de loi de
finances rectificative numéro 4 on a mis
assez de milliards d'euros en
anticipation pour permettre de re
confinés dans les conditions économiques
convié aujourd'hui le 1 milliard de là
que ça va coûter ces mesures nouvelles
dont 600 millions d'euros pour le fonds
de solidarité l'accompagnement des
entreprises par exemple où les 400
millions d'euros de chômage partiel se
sont là c'est de l'argent qui avait été
anticipé le fonds de solidarité on en
n'a pas manqué en novembre pourquoi
parce que grâce aux parlementaires on
avait voté une enveloppe beaucoup plus
large qui parle d' anticipation de ce
gouvernement à quel moment jamais
personne moi j'aimerais qu'on compare le
site qu'on fait plutôt pas mal
les écoles sont ouvertes économiquement
on n'a pas à rougir on a anticipé on est
là on n'accompagne on ne lâche rien il
ya aussi des choses qui marchent dans
notre plein de 5 sur les communes sur
les commerces sur la dz territorialisée
adaptées aux territoires plus confiné
que les autres on va dire oui en toute
logique
et puis a aussi un énorme sujet sur les
coûts fixes depuis d'ailleurs le
confinement de novembre si c'est un
problème je pense aux structures qui
font un chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 1
million d'euros qui sont des désordres
des grosses pme ou des entreprises
citadines avec beaucoup de charges fixes
avec des loyers très important qui
connaissent des fermetures depuis des
mois on est en train à bercy de bâtir un
dispositif de prise en charge des coûts
fixes qui pourrait aller jusqu'à 10
millions d'euros pour les entreprises de
plus d'un million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est un engagement de bruno
le maire je peux vous dire que jour et
nuit on y travaille à bercy et j'en
profite parce que c'est assez rare pour
ça lui aussi les administrations qui
travaillent jour et nuit
la dg philippe la dg
notamment on les critique souvent les
saluera rebonds et ce après il sera prêt
quand ce nouveau plan il serait annoncé
qu'en nez dessus dès que c'est possible
je pense que déjà ce sera plus clair en
fin de semaine on est dessus jour et
nuit donc les arbitrages seront des
questions d'être sur ces questions de
liste des commerces ouverts y aura de
nouvelles annonces à priori jeudi au
point presse de chouib le mans
possiblement et ce sera bruno le maire
aux côtés d'alain grézac ix et exprima
nature on va parler de votre dos de vos
dossiers particulièrement de l'économie
sociale et solidaire est ce que juste
pour démarrer ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quelles sont les activités de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
souffre le plus en ce moment est celle
qui se porte bien ce qu'il ya déjà des
il ya des différences assez notable
entre les différents secteurs très juste
alors ça je dirais un peu comme dans le
reste de l'économie en même temps c'est
une économie à part entière donc vous
aider des écosystèmes comme les
ressourceries les recycleries sont en
plein foisonnement dans notre pays j'en
profite pour leur dire qu'il ya un appel
à projets dont les censeurs s'en balance
alors ça s'est ouvert il ya une
appétence il ya une envie mais il ya des
conditions sanitaires qui rendent les
choses quand même difficile j'étais
encore il ya à près de och à valoriser
dans une ressourcerie dans le gers c'est
compliqué quand on vous amène des objets
qu'il faut mettre en sas de
décontamination qu'il faut nettoyer en
sus et qu'il faut remettre au réemploi
ensuite donc je dirais que la chaîne de
production elle est hyper complexe et
donc cela typiquement il ya des
difficultés parce que dans les
conditions sanitaires c'est pas évident
je pense al'inverse par exemple à des
structures on a beaucoup ça dans nos
territoires des structures de de
maraîchage bio local
le fait qu'on soit souvent chez soi et
ramener chez soi et à rester chez soi
fait qu'on essaye de se faire des petits
plaisirs aussi de manger mieux de
peut-être d'aller découvrir la ferme de
la collectivité d'à côté qu'on avait
jamais le temps d'aller voir quand on
bossait et d'aller acheter des paniers
bio locaux et là je dois dire que c'est
devant qu'elle soit en ligne d'ailleurs
au physique de produits 100 bio locaux
souvent déployées par des acteurs
coopérative de le ss ça marche plutôt
bien et ça se développe super bien donc
il ya vraiment des activités qui
souffrent évidemment parmi celles qui
souffrent évidemment il ya les petites
associations petite association qui
depuis un an vivre un enfer
didier en janvier que vous aviez les
petites associations employeurs donc
celles qui ont moins de 10 salariés
vous estimez qu'il avait trente mille
qui était en très grande difficulté du
fait de cette crise le fonds d'urgence
de 30 millions d'euros que vous avez
mobilisé est-ce qu'il a suffi à soutenir
à soutenir ces structures où on est
encore en perte en ligne
on est en plein dedans il ya peu de pas
de perte en ligne est en réalité je vous
donne deux chiffres 10 9 milliards
d'euros du fonds de solidarité au global
décaissé depuis mars 2020 sur 19
milliards d'euros c'est 200 250 millions
d'euros pour les associations terre des
associations qui ont demandé de l'aide
et qui ont demandé le fonds de
solidarité c'est dire si ces petits par
rapport à la masse qui a été mobilisés
par l'état et donc on s'est rendu compte
dès l'été dernier de ces chiffres et
j'ai mis en place effectivement c'est 30
millions c'est 30 millions
supplémentaires qui viennent très
simplement à partir d'un site en urgence
tirait es point fr qui permettent aux
structures de l'ess s de moins de 10
salariés notamment aux associations de
bénéficier en quinze jours d'un
diagnostic par france active et de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une aide allant
jusqu'à 5000 euros pour les structures
jusqu'à trois salariés jetés à 8000
euros pour les structures allant jusqu'à
10 salariés
c'est une aide qui est très simple et
qui se déploie très vite c'est très
important compte tenu des difficultés
rencontrées
je prends souvent cet exemple d'une
petite association culturelle qui n'a
pas pu faire les spectacles qu'elle
souhaitait au printemps dernier qui n'a
pas forcément refait sa trésorerie à la
rentrée parce que les parents parce que
des adultes sont dit est-ce que je re
cotisent sur l'année vu les conditions
sanitaires qui s'est retrouvé janvier
février dans des situations très
difficiles donc on est aujourd'hui pour
tout vous dire à 10 millions d'euros
déjà décaissé 1600 structures déjà aidé
et on continue plus de 7000 demandes en
plus de 7700 demande sur le site qu'on a
mis en place on espère sauver très
concrètement cinq à dix mille
association avec ce fonds d'urgence et
je vous remercie de me reposer la
question ça me permet de redire aux
assauts notamment allez-y connectez vous
demander cette aide
100% des gagnants ont tenté leur chance
en ne demandant rien vous ne pourrez pas
l'avoir prenait 10 minutes de votre
temps pour le faire et on précise bien
que les ss et l'économie sociale et
solidaire pour tous ceux qui nous
écoutent stéphane le jeu je me sers
aussi dans le plan de relance il ya 1,3
milliard d'euros qui sont prévus pour
développer l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est un montant énorme c'est
du jamais vu
pour ce secteur là en même temps
l'économie sociale et solidaire
aujourd'hui c'est 10% du pg 14 % des
emplois il n'y a pas un décalage entre
le poids que pèse cette économie par
rapport aux moyens qui lui sont alloués
même si c'est beaucoup avec 3 milliards
sur 100 milliards ça fait qu'un pour
cent
alors oui c'est pour son règne la règle
de trois ailes et elle est logique et ça
n'est pas la première fois qu'on
m'interroge dessus je pense que ce qui
est important dans votre question
d'avancer de caractère inédit jamais
cette économie qui représente
effectivement 10% du pib 14 % de nos
emplois salariés
jamais cette économie n'a eu plus d'un
milliard d'euros d'investissements
déployables en 12 24 mois donc déjà
c'est quand même une petite partie oui
mais je dirais d'abord ce n'est pas la
seule partie si vous voyez autorisé
parce que j'ai eu l'honnêteté de
préciser ce qui était directement
rattaché à l'économie sociale et
solidaire mais il ya aussi ce qui est
indirectement attaché mais qui est
quelque part de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
écrit par les 2,2 milliards 9 donc
servir qui a quasiment 3 milliards en
plus on dirait que je prends deux
exemples encore une fois dû issues du
terrain parce que c'est là que l'on voit
les résultats de notre politique ou
paris
j'avais cette ressourcerie à vallauris
qui va pouvoir candidater à l'appel à
projets sur l'économie circulaire 350
millions d'euros que je ne compte pas
dans le milliard 3 et sur l'agroécologie
qui est extrêmement points dans ces
départements ruraux
il y à des sommes importantes à et
julien de normandie qu'on déploie pour
faire bouger les chaînes de production
notamment dans la ruralité en faveur du
bio et produits plus durables donc il ya
aussi une enveloppe de quasiment 3
milliards en plus de ce milliard 3 est
tout ce qui compte aujourd'hui au delà
de la bataille de chiffres et on l'a vu
sur les assauts avec le non recours
c'est que les acteurs de ssl se saisir
de ces appels à projets ils répondent et
je peux vous dire si le milliard 3 et
débloqué décaissés dans les mois qui
viennent d'ici l'été
j'aurais assez d'énergie pour en
demander plus et et augmenter le budget
vous aviez lancé un dispositif de
contrat impact à l'automne aussi pour
notamment pour amener le comment la le
l'investissement privé à s'intéresser à
la sf est ce que ça marche ce genre de
choses ça marche
voilà où ici
un sujet sur lequel on m'avait dit avec
enthousiasme à la rentrée mais ça ne
marchera jamais c'est mal calibré c'est
trop compliqué c'est pas dans la culture
de tous et hurle il est une mille et une
explication sur le fait que nous
n'allions pas y arriver et notamment que
les acteurs de le ss était trop petit
trop dispersée trop fragmenté qui
manquait parfois d'ambition pour aller
demander des projets un million de
millions 3 millions pour le faire passer
à l'échelle tout ça il faut voilà donc
premier contre un impact économie
circulaire on avait mis 10 millions
d'euros avec l'ademe que je remercie
arnaud leroy qui est très engagée sur ce
sujet en faveur de l'économie circulaire
on a eu plus d'une quarantaine de
candidatures et on a décidé devant la
qualité des dossiers transmis par les
porteurs de projets notamment associatif
de tripler les enveloppes pour l'amener
à un peu plus de 27 millions d'euros
pour un dispositif qui marche pas juste
une bonne nouvelle le deuxième égalité
des chances économiques on est en plein
dans la sélection et le troisième a été
ouvert il ya une dizaine de jours le 3
mars dernier avec elisabeth bornes sur
l'insertion et sur la mobilité dans
l'insertion qui est un vrai sujet les
contrats impact ça commence à
fonctionner beaucoup d'acteurs s'y
intéressent et notamment les acteurs
financiers et des acteurs très
traditionnel donc on ouvre les fenêtres
de l'économie sociale un dernier mot là
dessus les les français ont beaucoup
épargné pendant cette crise en tout cas
ceux qui ont pu le faire est ce que vous
souhaitez qu'une partie de cette épargne
bénéficier à l'économie sociale et
solidaire et comment vous allez faire
c'est déjà le cas au sein d'une très
belle loi qui s'appelait la loi pacte il
ya un schéma est radieux que
j'affectionne tout particulièrement sur
l'orientation de l'héparine vous ne le
savez peut-être pas mais ici autour de 7
à vous avez déjà depuis le 1er janvier
2020 une unité de compte en faveur de la
finance durable de la finance solidaire
ou de l'investissement socialement
responsable
ce sera trois unités de comptes à
compter de janvier 2022 ce qui vient de
chaque contrat d'assurance vie des
français il y aura de l'épargné fléché
en faveur d' actifs durable et solidaire
il ya aussi les fonds à 90,10 sur
lesquels nous travaillons qui permettent
d'orienter une partie de l'épargné au
service de projets sociaux solidaire
nous regardons actuellement avec la
banque de france et je proposerai
peut-être des pistes d'ici l'été pour
augmenter cette part des parcs mais il
ya une chose que je trouve
encourageantes et comme vous l'avez
remarqué je cherche des signaux
d'optimisme dans un d'une
vers un peu tristoune ils n'ont pas
attendu les français pour orienter leurs
épargnes et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
quand vous regardez l'investissement
socialement responsable il a fait x 5
ces dernières années quand vous regardez
les greens fine finance verte
elle a fait foi cette dans les actifs
des français donc la tendance est là le
mouvement de fond est là à nous de
l'accompagner justement alors la
tendance est là juste peut-être une
précision et un sujet c'est qu'on n'est
pas dans l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais pas loin les entreprises à mission
la semaine dernière mais elle faber le
patron de danone a été débarqué par par
son conseil d'administration est ce que
ça c'est pas un très mauvais signe qu'il
ya une tendance qui se développe sur le
club capitalisme à visage humain une
façon de faire les choses différemment
le monde d'après etc et en même temps là
on voit que vous avez un grand patron la
première entreprise du cac 40 qui est
une petite entreprise à mission le grand
patron qui se fait rattraper par la
patrouille entre guillemets et à ramener
dans les clous par des actionnaires qui
exige d'avoir un profil old school trait
à l'ancienne plusieurs choses la
première par précaution il ya quand même
des règles et je m'y astreins en tant
que ministre membre du gouvernement je
rende pas en termes de commentaires dans
la gouvernance à proprement parler que
ce soit d'ailleurs de danone ou de toute
autre entreprise
en revanche comme je suis une femme qui
prend ses responsabilités je vous dirais
qu'il ya plusieurs lectures différentes
et qu'il faut avoir le livre bien ouvert
qu'il y a c'est plus qu'une tendance sur
le capitalisme responsable
il ya aujourd'hui un alignement des
planètes et la finance n'est pas en
reste on en parlera sûrement qui
poussent en faveur de ce capitalisme
plus responsable il ya aussi une réalité
c'est que jamais ni bruno le maire dit
moi-même avons exprimé le fait que
devenir une entreprise a mission faire
bouger une raison d'être
devenir une fondation dictionnaire on en
parle assez peu mais c'est le troisième
niveau après société a mission n'engage
à rien ne pas être performant n'engage à
rien on n'engage en rien ne pas avoir
une bonne performance économique et être
une société à mission n'est pas être une
société moins rentables moins
performante
c'est une société qui demeure rentable
et performante tout en faisant des choix
en faveur de ses missions donc vous
voyez pas comme un mauvais signe je le
alors je pourrais être très encore plus
précise
parlons aussi de ces entreprises
émissions qui sont en train de se créer
moi j'entends que c'est haro sur danone
parce que c'est là
le bois du cac aujourd'hui côté bon ont
d'abord jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
n'est pas question qu'ils ne soient plus
entreprises à mission enfin ou alors
j'ai pas eu l'info et deuxièmement on
parle jamais ces entreprises qui le
deviennent plus de quasiment 150 en
quelques mois et notamment au sein du
cac40 donc c'est une arnaque à 9,8 à la
fin de l'année il y en a 150 jours voilà
donc ça avance et la crise la crise
accélère le mouvement et on a vu ce post
crise et deux questions de l'actualité
pour terminer olivia grégoire et d'abord
cette polémique concernant l'unef qui
prend de l'ampleur
sa présidente de l'unef a évoqué que
leur l'organisation de réunions
interdites aux blancs pour permettre aux
personnes touchées par le racisme
d'exprimer ce qu'elle subisse jean
michel blanc caramélisées l'éducation
nationale il parle de choses qui
s'apparente au fascisme
est-ce qu'il faut couper les subventions
publiques à l'unef est ce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'à 10 ou de l'unef pour vous
alors c'est pas à moi qui suis en charge
de ces sujets et ça n'est pas moi qui
m'exprime sur des 10e lichans impossible
c'est jean michel blanquer en priorité
et le pré ministre
je crois que en revanche continuer à
soutenir avec des deniers publics
une association qui promeut ce type de
discours extrêmement dangereux enfin je
veux dire c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire
que moi si j'avais été étudiante il ya
quelques années ce que j'étais j'aurais
pas eu le droit de m'exprimer parce que
j'avais pas la bonne couleur de peau par
rapport à un enjeu fin je sais pas si on
mesure réellement le le caractère grave
de ces propos et de cette vision plus
largement de la société vision quasiment
sans fin une vision séparatistes une
vision raciste le racisme étant des deux
côtés je suis très mme je suis très
frappé et en même temps pas vraiment
étonné de par ses propositions ça fait
quelques temps que l'unef à des
positions plus qu'étonnante et je pense
que ce soit la dissolution que ce soit
les subventions publiques
il faut trouver une solution c'est pas à
moi de dire laquelle mais il faut en
trouver nous et stéphane une dernière
question sur les régionales une question
politique est ce que le report des
régionales est toujours d'actualité
enfin ce qu'est ce que ça fait partie
des choses qui sont encore sur la table
à nouveau sur la table
et question subsidiaire quel sera votre
rôle à vous personnellement dans les
régionales à venir alors première
question
dans l'ordre et comme tout nous est
reproché notamment l'ordre des choses
j'aimerais le rappeler on attend de voir
comment la situation sanitaire est venu
dans les prochaines semaines on attend
ici autour du 1er avril un autre avis de
pensée symbolique et voilà sur 7 sur ce
sujet c'est à l'aune de ces éléments
notamment sanitaires et de la position
du conseil scientifique que des
décisions pourraient être prendre elles
ne sont absolument pas à l'ordre du jour
au moment où je vous parle aujourd'hui
ça n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
deuxièmement sur mon rôle mon rôle sera
comme je le suis toujours entière engagé
et loyal je ne serai pas physiquement
sur une liste candidate je ne serai pas
candidate mais je serais super une
campagne je participe activement
amicalement et avec beaucoup d'espoir à
la campagne de l'excellent laurent saint
martin en ile-de-france en ile de france
avec beaucoup de personnes et
personnalités marcheurs à ses côtés un
état d'esprit un projet une façon de
faire de la politique qui me parlent
donc il sait qu'il pourra compter sur
moi tout au long de cette campagne
régionale qui s'annonce difficile mais
c'est un homme courageux donc on verra
et on n'est pas à l'abri de résultats
chouette est de voir émerger aussi ce
qu'ils achètent ça veut dire que ça
serait une surprise si gagner laurent
saint martin est un vrai rugbyman et
qu'en tireront sur un terrain il faut
attendre la fin du match et vous
viendrez nous en reparler merci beaucoup
merci
invité ce matin à la une de ouest france
un sujet qui va vous intéresser oliva
grégoire ces entreprises à mission qui
ne vise pas le seul profit c'est là une
de ouest france aujourd'hui merci
stéphane merci et ont fait sous tito
club des territoires la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics
vous présente le club des terribles
[Musique]